und heute sprechen wir mal über die
ultimative Bedrohung Klimawandel das 1,5
Grad Ziel ist kaum noch zu erreichen
nee warte mal ich habe mich komplett
vertan die größte Bedrohung sind
natürlich Aktivisten die sich auf
Straßen festkleben und Gemälde mit
Tomatensuppe bewerfen ja
ja Alexander Dobrindt CSU warnt jetzt
vor der Entstehung einer neuen
klimaereif kleiner haben wir es nicht
oder
warum nicht gleich altklipida oder sowas
der Klima Terror steht vor der Tür also
das behaupten jedenfalls bestimmte
Medien in Dauerschleife extrem
aufgeheizte Debatte die klimakleber ich
nenne sie eher klimakriminelle das sind
Extremisten ökoextremisten mit
ökoextremisten neue kleine klima-f
Chaoten es sind Extremisten es sind
Kriminelle grüne RAF eine grüne RAF sind
auch zutiefst asozial was sie da machen
klimakleber nicht etwas niedlich das
sind Kriminelle
ruhig
alles wird gut ja keine Frage egal wie
wichtig das Anliegen Protest darf
natürlich nie Menschen gefährden logisch
trotzdem müssen wir doch zivilen
Ungehorsam von Terrorismus unterscheiden
die RAF Liebe jüngere Zuschauer ihr
könnt das nicht wissen war schon eine
andere Liga was man unter anderem an den
Fahndungsplakaten von damals erkennt da
stand nämlich Vorsicht Schusswaffen und
eben nicht vor sich Dosensuppen ja
der Vergleich hinkt hinten und vorne die
RF hatte zum Beispiel Sympathisanten und
leider
leider hilft die letzte Generation
ziemlich aufgeblasener Name übrigens mit
ihren Aktionen Leuten wie Dobrindt beim
ablenken klar reden Politiker ungern
über ihre Versäumnisse beim Klimaschutz
und viel viel lieber über härtere
Strafen für klimakleber klimakleber die
größte Bedrohung
klimakleber deren konkrete Forderungen
ultigerweise kaum einer kennt im Kern
wollen die Achtung das 9 Euro Ticket und
Tempo 100 auf Autobahnen ändert aber
nichts an der latenten münchstimmung in
Teilen der Bevölkerung
wenn man die nicht einfach überfahren
ich fand das leider interessant muss ich
sagen
leider leider gibt's hier immer noch
Regeln sie können die erst überfahren
wenn die Ampel grün ist vorher nicht
sobald die Volksseele einmal richtig
hoch kocht ist man ganz schnell eine
terroristische Vereinigung
Entschuldigung was ich ja was ich
persönlich rätselhaft finde ist die
Sache mit den Kunstwerken meine jeder
Maler dessen Bild noch nicht mit Essen
beworfen wurde muss ich inzwischen
fragen was er falsch macht und
Aufmerksamkeit für Klimaschutz hin oder
her irgendwann wird es halt Alltag wie
die aufgeregte Reaktion dieses
museumswertes beweist
hallo
Tag
grüß Gott
ganz kurze kritische Off Topic Anmerkung
von mir sie haben es gesehen der
Kartoffelbrei war natürlich viel zu dünn
da fehlte Butter ne
und achten Sie bitte doch nochmal auf
die Reaktionen der anderen Besucher die
angeklebten vorne halten laute Vorträge
alle anderen gucken sich einfach
umgerührt weiter die Ausstellung an
jetzt das meine ich es wird irgendwann
Routine
als nächstes bringen sich
Museumsbesucher Tupperdosen mit um den
Kartoffelbrei mit nach Hause zu nehmen
ja und am Ende wird der ganze Aktivismus
wahrscheinlich kommerziell na keinen
Bock auf sonntags Kaffee bei Tante Hilde
die Ballettaufführung der Tochter den
spielerabend mit dem netten Paar dass
sie im Urlaub kennengelernt habt dann
rufen Sie jetzt an bei rent a Klima
Kleber unsere Aktivisten verschaffen
Ihnen die beste Ausrede aller Zeiten oh
nein jetzt können wir noch nicht mal zum
Geburtstag von deiner Mutter blöder
klimaaktivist wir klicken uns für Sie
überall fest beim Zahnarzt vor der
Wurzelbehandlung samstags am Rasenmäher
wir blockieren sogar ihre Kinosessel
damit sie den neuen Til Schweiger Film
nicht sehen müssen und jetzt neu wenn
sie genervt sind von den beschissen
gemalten Bildern ihrer Kinder mieten Sie
doch einen unserer
tomatensuppenschmeißer Problem gelöst
rent a klimakleber
[Musik]
nicht schlecht
nicht schlecht so ob eine Demo der
letzten Generation Mitverantwortung am
Tod einer Radfahrerin in Berlin trägt
ist juristisch nicht geklärt trotzdem
wäre spätestens diese Tragödie Anlass
sich auch mal neue Protestformen
auszudenken in neulich in Amsterdam hat
man sich ein Privatjets gekettet das
fand ich erfrischend muss ich sagen aber
reden wir bitte auch mal über den
Freistaat Bayern dort wurden gerade
zwölf Aktivisten wohlgemerkt ohne
Anklage in sogenannte unterbindungshaft
genommen
andererseits kein schlechter Zeitpunkt
für Knast in Bayern gerade kocht der
Alfons Schuhbeck
aber trotzdem ich sag's noch mal Haft
ohne Anklage ist Bayern eigentlich noch
ein Rechtsstaat was ist jemand oder
oder geht das doch mehr in Richtung
Bananenrepublik ja genau so funktioniert
Populismus er weiß das den Leuten immer
sagen was Sie gerade hören wollen nicht
leichte Geldstrafen sondern auch mal
tatsächlich
beispielsweise ein Arist oder eine
entsprechende Haftstrafe wenn es dann um
besonders schwere Fälle geht sprach der
Fleisch gewordene Stammtisch die
vorbeugehaft wurde 2017 mit dem
sogenannten bayerischen
polizeiaufgabengesetz eingeführt um
Achtung schwere terroristische
Straftaten zu verhindern wie zum
Beispiel das beschädigen von
Bilderrahmen in Museen aber so ist er
dabei ob Islamist Aktivist oder einfach
nur Nervensäge wer nicht spurt wird
weggesperrt
glaube ich spielen was klebst du dich in
meiner Werkstatt fest
das immer gleich die Speer schön in
präventiv auf du nerviger Arsch
Oma
[Musik]
Schweiß
kann ich immer furchtbar links grün
versiffter Kobold ernsthaft barfuß und
rote Haare da weißt du doch direkt
Bescheid
30 Tage unterbindungshaft in Bayern ist
das schon das Ende der Fahnenstange oder
kommt dann noch mehr natürlich kommt da
noch mehr Martin klemmt nur leitete
München die neue soko-klima Terror Thema
heute sind die Methoden des Gegners ja
gute die musst du schon kennen die
Tricks von dieser kleinen
öko-kleberprotzen unser Volker der klebt
sich hier gerade mal fest und der
Kollege muss ihn wieder loskriegen den
ungewaschenen Chaoten bitte
erlösungsmittel das dauert der ewig ich
zeige euch mal wie man die Pfoten
schneller frei kriegt
das mit der Präventivhaft ist in jedem
Fall akkuronform aber da geht natürlich
noch viel mehr meine Soko greift durch
bevor einer auf dumme Ideen kommt zum
Beispiel im Baumarkt da hängen wir nicht
umsonst Videokameras
Sekundenkleber in welchem Gang sie
haben die Handschellen im Auto gelassen
servus habt ihr vielleicht der
Kabelbinder
eine verdächtig große Portion
Kartoffelbrei machen oder wenn sich
irgendso ein Eierkopf im Museum ein Bild
länger als absolut nötig anschaut
da wird nichts lange gefackelt gerade
habe ich zum Beispiel von einem
Informanten erfahren dass direkt nebenan
in einem Gymnasium im Unterricht über
den sogenannten Klimawandel geredet wird
und da wundern wir uns wenn die Kinder
sich radikalisieren so aber was steht
denn im Pariser Klimaabkommen
hallo hallo
ihr seid der frühesten sind 30 Tagen
wieder
hast wie ein bayerisches naked Scooter
Nord so und bei aller Kritik
selbstverständlich kann man den Frust
der Aktivisten sehr sehr gut verstehen
in Sharm el Sheikh findet gerade der 27
Weltklimagipfel statt ja wie immer
werden sich die Staaten der Welt zu den
Pariser Klimazielen bekennen und dann
Politik machen deren Erreichung
unmöglich macht oder so gut wie
unmöglich außerdem Klimagipfel
ausgerechnet in Ägypten also einem
lupenreinen Polizeistaat gesponsert von
Achtung Coca-Cola
ja das kannst du dir nicht ausdecken die
neue Cola Zero Toleranz gegen
Demonstranten Olaf Scholz Olaf Scholz
fliegt diese Woche dahin und sagt mit
angemessenem Pathos in der Stimme es
darf keine weltweite Renaissance der
fossilen Energien geben und für
Deutschland sage ich es wird sie auch
nicht geben
und das sage ich während wir in
Deutschland Kohlekraftwerke wieder
hochfahren
ist das Dialektik oder versuchter
neuerdings witzig zu sein ist es das es
wirklich ich verstehe es nicht ja wir
lesen doch alle Zeitungen Deutschland
Hilft demnächst dem Senegal größere
Gasvorkommen auszubeuten und die
ampelaner fliegen nach Ägypten ohne
neues klimagesetz nur mit einem
Eckpunktepapier das den Verkehr komplett
ausspart wir haben in die
Ressortabstimmung das Klimaschutz
Sofortprogramm gegeben das Klimaschutz
Sofortprogramm dann haben wir sofort ist
inzwischen so ein bisschen naja aber ein
Klimaschutzprogramm gegeben naja und wo
ich so drüber nachdenke Schutz müssen
wir ebenfalls streichen und Programm
stimmt auch nicht mehr aber sonst läuft
Klima stimmt noch im Verkehrssektor
bleibt genau eine klimaschutzmaßnahme
mit der die Ampel so ein bisschen
angeben könnte das 49 euro-ticket das
kommt
schnellstmöglich heißt es aha Gernot
Hassknecht kann es abwarten
gernotasknecht und die hässliche
Wahrheit über das 49 Euro Ticket
viel zu einfach aber manchmal muss es
eben sein ich stehe hier im ICE nach
Osnabrück wir sind aber heute morgen
über Passau umgeleitet worden und gleich
muss ich mein ekliges iPod essen weil
das Wort Restaurant Überraschung zu hat
49 Euro Ticket schön und gut aber warum
machen wir die Bahn nicht erst mal
besser bevor wir sie billiger machen in
diesem Sommer waren nur noch 57% der
Fernzüge pünktlich in Japan müsste der
komplette Bahnvorstand Harakiri machen
japanische Züge sind bekannt für ihre
Pünktlichkeit die durchschnittliche
Verspätung beträgt beneidenswerte 36
Sekunden
ein Deutscher brandkunde kennt die
Maßeinheit gar nicht Stunden Worten klar
aber was bitte sind Sekunden kein Wunder
der
bahninvestitionsstau liegt bei knapp 60
Milliarden Euro eine Milliarde will die
Ampel zusätzlich pro Jahr für Erhalt und
Ausbau des Nahverkehrs spendieren viel
zu wenig
andererseits wenn noch Geld übrig ist
für so entgeile Bahn Spots guck mal wir
fahren unter Wasser und dann sind wir
auf einmal in Afrika toll wie sind wir
da denn hingekommen
will
keiner helfen ich will einfach nur ins
verkackte Osnabrück ist das zu viel
verlangt und haben sie das neulich im
Spiegel gelesen wenn ein Mitglied der
Bundesregierung ICE fährt greift die
geheime konzernrichtlinie
199 dann werden alle Hebel in Bewegung
gesetzt dass der zu pünktlich ist der
wird regelrecht sauber gemacht und die
Klimaanlage funktioniert ja das geht
sehr geehrte Fahrgäste in Passau steigt
Verkehrsminister Volker Wissing zu
deswegen öffnet gleich unser
Bordrestaurant der Minister möchte
allerdings alleine speisen danke für Ihr
Verständnis
leider kein Witz wenn Minister reisen
müssen andere Züge auf der Strecke
warten aber da sitzt ja auch nur der
Pöbel drin so mir reicht's ihr zwingt
mich zum Äußersten ich öffne jetzt meine
ipodose und löse damit eine
massenpanisch aus
dem das Wissen
nimm das
gerne passt nicht und die hässliche
Wahrheit über das 49 Euro Ticket
ach ja die Ampel sie meint ja gut wenn
nur die verdammte Realität nicht wäre ne
da klappen dann Anspruch und
Wirklichkeit oft weit auseinander
übrigens nicht nur beim Klima sondern
auch beim neuen
eu-lieferkettengesetzt das war
eigentlich ganz gut das Gesetz bevor
ausgerechnet Deutschland angefangen hat
es hinter den Brüsseler Kulissen zu
sagen wir mal entkernen bzw zu
massakrieren wenn wir ganz ehrlich sind
ja geliebte Papiere Papiere und
Recherchen von Monitor legen nahe dass
die Ampel hier einmal mehr den
Wunschzettel der Wirtschaftslobbyisten
abarbeitet sie fordern eine
Sonderregelung die sogenannte
safe-haber-klausel
und erstaunlich in internen Weisungen
der Bundesregierung findet sich nun
exakt die gleiche Forderung
peinlich wenn man beim Abschreiben
erwischt wird Safe ist das der sichere
Hafen der wir neulich den Chinesen
vertickt habe
nein nicht stimmt safe Harper bedeutet
Firmen kaufen sich ein Zertifikat in dem
steht bei euch alles tippi toppi in
Sachen Menschenrechte und dann ist man
raus als Firma raus aus der
Verantwortung das Unternehmen haftet nur
noch bei grober Fahrlässigkeit oder
Vorsatz für Opfer im Ausland kaum
nachweisbar in der Praxis 2019 ist zum
Beispiel in Brasilien ein Staudamm
gebrochen der erst ein Jahr vorher vom
deutschen TÜV SÜD für sicher erklärt
wurde ja gibt's passiert
Vorschlag um es noch einfacher zu machen
für die deutschen Firmen mit
problematischer Lieferkette die füllen
einfach in Zukunft ein Online-Formular
aus da steht dann wissen Sie von
Kinderarbeit in ihrer Lieferkette und
dann kreuzt man an entweder nein nein
mit zwinker emoji oder nee aber wenn ich
was höre melde ich mich versprochen nee
fertig ja zertifiziert so schade extrem
schade dass eu-lieferkettengesetz
enthielt richtig viel Schönes bevor
Deutschland sich eingemischt hat und ich
sag mal so vor einem Jahr klang das
alles noch irgendwie anders egal welche
Klamotten oder Schuhe wir einkaufen
Kinderarbeit oder Ausbeutung sollte nie
Teil ihrer Herstellung sein garantiert
durch ein lieferkettengesetz mit 10 und
bis
wow ein lieferkettengesetz mit Zähnen
und bist geile Idee oder ich finde es
super richtig gut ja
sorry Wirtschaft ist sein Ressort da
hängt er jetzt mit drin auch beim Thema
Risikoanalyse das geht so wenn
Deutschland sich dadurch setzt haften
Firmen nur noch für Risiken die sie
selber vorher als schwerwiegend
eingestuft haben ja die Bundesregierung
schlägt konkret vor werden riesigen
zunächst unbeachtet gelassen von der
Firma so gelten die Schäden als nicht
vorhersehbar und unvermeidbar ist cool
oder das heißt übersetzt weggucken wird
belohnt und wissen Sie welche
ampelpartei sich hinter den Kulissen
wohl besonders stark macht um das
lieferkettengesetz an weiteren Stellen
aufzuweichen es folgt der am wenigsten
überraschende Moment in der Geschichte
der heute-show
und jetzt alle es ist die
woher wisst ihr das ist ja unheimlich ja
tatsächlich so berichten Insider pocht
wohl vor allem FDP Justizminister
Buschmann auf die Entschärfung des
Gesetzes
so Tatsache ist ein konsequent
umgesetztes lieferkettengesetz könnte
für die deutsche Wirtschaft zum Problem
werden zum Beispiel wenn man in China
produziert und eigentlich immer damit
rechnen muss dass einzelne Teile eben
doch von Uiguren in Zwangsarbeit stammen
nicht zufällig ist Olaf Scholz ja gerade
erst mit prominenten deutschen Firmen
Bossen nach China geflogen quasi als
oberster deutscher Klinkenputzer kann
man machen
kann man machen aber
der eine Hamburger Publikum lacht so
schön
warum so kurz nach Präsident
schieß erteilt hat unmittelbar danach
war doch klar dass die in Peking das als
Kotau verkaufen die chinesische
Staatspropaganda hat ein Lieblingsbild
vom deutschen Kanzler zehnmal wiederholt
sie das identische Bild seines nickens
während er den Worten von Staatschef
hier den Ping lauscht
aus einem Nicken machen die Säcke zehn
die reißen alles aus dem Zusammenhang
wie die heute-show da geht doch nicht
das geht doch nicht und der Kanzler
steht da wie so ein unterwürfiger
wackelpiginese kann man ihn machen kann
man nicht machen sicher Menschenrechte
wurden da auch mal angesprochen aber ich
sag mal so deswegen sind die
Konzernchefs nicht mitgeflogen natürlich
nicht ja BASF BASF zum Beispiel baut
sein China Geschäft aktuell sogar noch
aus allein vW hat da über 30 Werke und
wenn es wegen Taiwan wo fast alle Chips
herkommen die in deutscher Elektronik
verbaut werden irgendwann wirklich zu
einem Handel kommt ja dann wird es aber
richtig eng Freunde ohne Chips geht der
Wagen hier nicht mal auf können Sie mir
irgendeinen Bestandteil dieses Autos
nennen das ohne Chips auskommt das waren
Dreieck
noch sagt er noch ja das letzte was wir
noch ohne fremde Hilfe bauen können
Warndreiecke ja 80 Prozent unserer
Laptops kommen aus China 70 Prozent der
Handys und am schockierendsten 100%
unserer Barbie-Puppen meine Damen und
Herren wirklich traurig und um zu
erklären warum wir dringend ein
lieferkettengesetz mit Zähnen brauchen
genügt übrigens ein Wort she in so heißt
er vielleicht schlimmste fashion Content
des Planeten kommt aus China und
bombardiert online die ganze Welt mit
sogenannter ultra fast fashion also
blitzschneller wegwerfmode wann sind wir
auf der Seite also ist jetzt nicht das
eigentliche Thema aber ich finde auch
das Frauenbild interessant und das
Männerbild naja naja
das ist natürlich alles Geschmackssache
7 bis 8.000 neue Produkte hauen die da
jeden Tag ultra fast raus jeden Tag es
ist Wahnsinn und wir schalten mal live
zu Valerie Niehaus und Matthias Matschke
die als fashion influencer in Dubai
Leben was macht sie in so attraktiv für
junge Menschen
hi hey schön dich zu sehen ey wir sind
voll die Fans von deiner Sendung ja
alles so viel besser seit du das
moderierst zu deiner Frage billig so
billig letzte secret billig also extreme
billig she in ist so geil billig es gibt
T-Shirts für 2 €. oh mein Gott dafür
kannst du bei H&M nicht mal klauen
ja aber das funktioniert ja nur weil in
den Ski in Sweatshops 75 Stunden die
Woche geschuftet wird und zwar 7 Tage
die Woche ja aber die Woche hat doch
auch sieben Tage das redet er denn was
meint er denn ich verstehe Dich ich auch
nicht er ist halt wahrscheinlich einfach
alt Oliver
Oliver she in ist eine globale Community
zusammengehalten von einer App du musst
ihm erklären was eine App ist nein danke
ich weiß was eine App ist
um die Kundinnen und Kunden an Schienen
zu binden bekommen sie Bonuspunkte wenn
Sie die App jeden Tag öffnen je mehr die
User in der App aktiv sind desto genauer
können die Algorithmen Vorhersagen bei
welchen Produkten sie schwach werden
wenn ich die App jeden Tag aufmache wird
es noch billiger
was ist da denn 60 60 Prozent der
weltweit produzierten Klamotten landen
innerhalb eines Jahres in der
Verbrennung oder auf der Deponie
Vollkatastrophe so jetzt aber echt mal
sorry ja der Hashtag she in hat bei tik
tok 43 Milliarden Aufrufe da muss man
sich für gar nichts mehr rechtfertigen
ja 26 Millionen Follower bei insta wie
viel hast du denn da bei insta Herr
welke
ich bin überhaupt nicht bei insta
das geht schon ist das erlaubt darf man
nicht bei insta sein keine Ahnung
vielleicht lebt er im Heim der tut mir
voll leid
she in ist viel nachhaltiger als viele
denken zum Beispiel recycelt der
Konzernen Ideen ja also die Ideen von
anderen denn wo Zara und Co einzelne
Elemente von High Fashion Marken
kopieren übernimmt sie in die
identischen looks vor allem von jungen
Designern und Labels
dann sollen sie ihre Designs halt nicht
ins Internet stellen was im Internet ist
gehört allen so ist die Rechtslage
außerdem entwickelt sich Hashi in
ständig weiter Mathias zeig mal den
neuesten Trend
[Musik]
so das ist mega ultra fast fashion der
Clou dieses Teil zerstört sich nach nur
30 Sekunden Tragen von selbst
[Musik]
es ist so hart Matthias du bist so hart
ich weiß
wir haben gesagt die sollen meinen
Lieblingswitz erzählen was mache ich
gerne also kommen ein Pferd Jeff Bezos
und der Papst in eine Bar sagt der
Barkeeper
abonniere endlich den verkackten heute
schon Kanal also geht doch